What I want to do in this
video is introduce you
to what I think is one of
the neatest ideas in computer
science, and that is recursion.
So the way that we've defined
this factorial function
in the last few
videos is actually
an iterative definition.
We are iterating
through different values
for this variable
i, and then we're
essentially taking those values,
adding one, then multiplying
those times our
original product.
And when we keep iterating
through all of that,
our eventual product
has all of the values
from 1 through the number
multiplied by each other,
and they're all sitting
in this variable product.
What I'm going to do here
is rewrite this program.
And what's cool
about functions--
I'm going to rewrite
this function.
What's cool about functions
are this function,
we just say, look, it returns
a factorial of a number.
We don't care how this
is actually written.
And so anything that's
using this function call,
no matter how I implement
it, as long as I implement it
correctly, it shouldn't
worry about it.
So as long as I implement the
guts of this function right,
even if I do it in a
very different way,
it shouldn't affect the
behavior of any of the functions
that call it.
So let's go ahead and try
to define this function
recursively.
And I think you're going to
find this slightly fascinating.
So I'm going to do it
a little bit different.
We're going to put some
conditionals in here as well.
So I'm going to say-- so
it's almost-- in some ways,
recursion is really
deep and complicated,
and on some levels, it's way
simpler than anything else.
So let me just put all
of this stuff down there.
So I'm going to say, look,
if the number-- you always
want to think about a base case.
What's a situation where kind
of the nugget or the smallest
values we can put into
for a number that'll
give us a decent response?
So we'll say, look,
if number is--
let's say if it's less
than or equal to 1,
so if it's less than or equal
to 1, let's just return.
Well, then it's factorial.
Let's just return
1, especially if we
want to have the same
behavior as the old function.
The old function,
regardless of whether we
put a 1 there, a 0
there, or actually,
even if we put a negative
1 or negative 2 there,
it always gave us the
factorial being equal to 1.
So that's exactly what
we're doing over here.
We're returning 1 if the
number is less than 1.
And this also defines
our base case.
I can even label it here.
So let me label--
this is our base case.
And you'll see what I mean
for a second by base case.
And what I'm about
to do now, this
is the really exciting
part about recursion.
If the number is not
less than or equal to 1,
so I could write
l if-- well, maybe
I'll just write l, actually.
So if the number is not
less than or equal to 1,
I'm going to return
something different.
And what I'm going to
return is that number
times the factorial--
times the factorial of one
less than that number.
Now, the reason why this
is fascinating and cool
and all the rest is I
just defined something
using that something.
So I just defined a
function called factorial,
and I defined it using the
definition of the function
factorial.
It is referring to itself.
This is what recursive
functions do.
But if you think about it--
and I'll diagram it out
in more detail in
the next video,
so hopefully it makes a
little bit more sense--
it should kind of work.
Because if you put a 1
or a 0 in for a number,
it'll just return 1.
What happens if the number is 2?
Well, if the number
is 2, it'll say, look,
the number is not less than
our 1, so I'll go over here.
So it says it'll return 2
times factorial of 2 minus 1,
or factorial of 1.
And then it'll call factorial
again, and factorial of 1
is just 1, so it'll
return 2 times 1.
So that'll work out for 2.
Try it for 3.
If you do a
factorial of 3, it'll
go down to this
clause over here,
because 3 is not less
than or equal to 1,
and it'll return 3 times
the factorial of 3 minus 1,
which is 2, the factorial of 2.
Well, we know it already
returns the right answer
for the factorial of 2, so
it'll return 3 times 2, which
is 6, which is a factorial of 3.
So hopefully you're
getting the gist of it.
Factorial of 4 is going to
work for the exact same reason.
It's going to boil down to
4 times the factorial of 3.
We know that it works
for the factorial of 3.
And just to prove
to you that I'm not
doing some type of crazy voodoo,
and that this will actually
work, let's try to
run the program.
Let's try to run the
program right here.
This is some stuff that
I was doing beforehand.
Let me just get rid of that.
So let's just run the program.
So all I've done
is I've redefined
the factorial function, but
I've redefined it recursively.
I won't have to
change the comments.
So let me save it, and let's
interpret this program.
Let's execute it and see if
it does what we need it to do.
All right.
So they're prompting
us for something.
Let's take the
factorial of 5-- 120.
And so once again,
our factorial program,
no matter what we put in there,
it gives us the right answer.
But what's really cool is
it's now doing it recursively.
When I do factorial of 6,
say, OK, factorial of 6.
Is 6 less than or equal to 1?
Well, no it's not, so
it goes to this else
clause right over here.
So then it says return 6
times the factorial of 5.
Then it says, OK,
let me remember
6 times the factorial of 5.
Let's figure out what
the factorial of 5 is.
Well, factorial of 5 is going to
be 5 times the factorial of 4.
And then that factorial of 4
is 4 times the factorial of 3,
all the way down to the
factorial of 1, which is 1.
And so it'll actually return 6
times 5 times 4 times 3 times
2 times 1.